[Music]
so a new tv spot for spider-man no way
home just released and there is a ton of
new footage so let's just get straight
into the footage and break it down so
the trailer starts off with doctor
strange saying um we tampered with the
fabric of reality and there's a new shot
of spider-man holding the cube which he
has stolen from doctor strange and he
has just been flung into this new
environment and it quickly cuts to a new
shot and we can see doc octopus in the
background here looking around looking
up in the ceiling this makes me think
that he has just been captured by doctor
strange he's been he's been put inside
of the prison in the cube i presume and
yeah just looking around and confused on
what this place is the next few shots is
a lot of crazy doctor strange stuff
going on and i gotta say some of the
best visuals we have seen from the movie
so far so the first shot here we have
the trains which we have seen before but
this is from a new angle and we can see
dr strange using his magic to his
advantage while trying to grab the cube
from spider-man which looks like he is
nearly successful in doing so moving on
we have an extended scene from the shot
of the last trailer where doctor strange
says they're coming through and we can't
stop them what we see here is it looks
like the multiverse is opening up or
another reality is breaking into this
one i'm not too sure but it's a very
nice looking shot and i'm really curious
to see what will actually happen in the
scene the next three shots look to be on
the bridge scene yes more bridge scene
footage but it's a bit of a different
shot here so spider-man is actually
webbed and he is being dragged off the
bridge onto the train before he stops
himself with dying spider we then have
an extended shot of mj and spider-man
here and then more footage of the doctor
strange and spider-man fight now going
to say the visuals for the spider-man
and doctor strange fight do look really
really good so i'm excited to see more
of this fight and i wonder to what
extent would doctor strange go to to try
to get this cube from peter now to end
off this tv spot we have some new
dialogue with ned and doctor strange
which i'll play for you now can't
believe i'm in the saints i'm saying
neither can i anyway that's about it for
this video guys so this tv spot was
jammed packed with new footage so let me
know what you guys think of this footage
in the comment section below and if you
did enjoy please like the video
subscribe and turn notifications on so
you don't miss future content thanks for
watching guys